[Music]
at the last Super Bowl there was a spot
for the popular Super Mario Brothers
movie since then many fans have been
eagerly awaiting more news about Mario
and Luigi's newest Adventure after all
the movie's release is not too far off
as Universal Pictures surprisingly
announced the waiting time will be
shortened a little for the fans of the
Italian plumber as in the countless
video games that have long been world
famous the story revolves around the
adventurous journey of Mario and
Princess Peach to an underground maze
the goal is to rescue Mario's brother
Luigi who has been kidnapped by the
ruthless and fearsome Bowser and is now
being held captive as could seen in the
trailer all sorts of characters from the
Super Mario universe will make an
appearance including Donkey Kong Cranky
Kong toad as well as the villain Bowser
and his henchmen more information will
be available at an upcoming Nintendo
Direct event on March 9th where among
other things they will show the final
trailer and get everyone excited before
the release meanwhile you're already
looking forward to the early theatrical
release on April 5th 2023
foreign
[Music]